währenddessen bereitet sich die stadt
köln auf dem fdp parteitag ende april im
maritim hotel vor 150 kölner kneipen und
clubs haben sich zur aktion kein kölsch
für nazis zusammengetan
unter anderem wurden
ja
unter anderem wurden zigtausend
bierdeckel mit diesem spruch gedruckt
der kollege ulrich von heesen heute
experte für bier relevante themen meldet
sich jetzt live aus der gaststätte zum
fröhlichen fußfehler in köln ist es
feurig wie sind sie denn diese aktion
naja ist ja im prinzip gut gemeint genau
wie meine eigene aktion kolja rechts
natürlich alles machen worum geht es da
ja sowieso also manchmal wege ich werde
hier bei einem souveränen umgang mit
idioten aus verbote sich die hörer in
dieser kneipe gibt es sogar einen
eigenen nazi stammtisch er da vorne so
und direkter nähe hat er wird den wiener
schulen stammtisch einige dieser netze
die preise nicht beweisen
so läuft das in der weltoffenen stadt
vor allen die gleichen fehler machen das
hervorragend egal was für eine hautfarbe
das egal
du wirst wie scheiße
ob das war für ihre burg sagt ja du mich
auch das ist köln herrlich und die afg
hat sich doch schon sehr sind liege fit
mit ihrer idiotisch reaktion
es geht um kein geld für nazis und dann
meldet sich die afg baden württemberg
beleidigt mit 200.000 bierdeckeln wollen
sie gezielt fdp-wähler diskriminieren
damit gibt jedoch zu retten
mit mir wird viel zu viel gemacht und
diese braun zweifel hausverbot für hocke
im maritim riesenthema in allen
zeitungen
ich habe aus verbot in allen großen
hotelketten darüber richtig keine
darüber wie sich dies auf
vorsicht
ich verstehe ihre frage
wir dürfen der alten ordnung helfen sich
als opfer zu fühlen wieso ändert der
bundestag nach fast 17 jahren die
geschäftsordnung nur zu verhindern dass
ein toter kfd zombie alterspräsident
wird
[Musik]
dass das so schmeckt wie der gau land
aussieht
warte mal das ist doch eine ganz neue
aktion nur künstler nazi die dürfe nur
noch diese pferde finden trägt
[Applaus]
jetzt gucke jetzt guck ich so sauer
[Musik]
mögliche dauer ich gebe jetzt eine runde
aus
[Applaus]